all about the Washington's
autobiographical family sitcom that
follows a gentleman named Joey
Washington who's retiring from a long
career as legend hip-hop royalty and
that man who plays this gentleman is
sitting to my right right now and then
which isin shows to Joseph Simmons aka
Reverend Ron good to see you Reverend
Yellin man what's thought Cydia and your
Adidas tracksuit yes man every day same
thing a closet is nothing but there's
different colors blonde
just black white I got one burgundy one
how many do you how many how many adidas
track suits do you own what's the total
do you know the grand total
well they ship some every couple of
weeks so I give them to charity also
sure and I have hundreds and hundreds in
my closet between that and my reverend
collar I go from it was a nice event as
well my Reverend collar yes my hat yes
and if it's just a place to come and
talk sports like with you yes okay I
like it so you are here in your adidas
suit so let's talk a little sports what
are the Knicks your team Knicks is my
team but I'm very interested in to see
what what LeBron is gonna do I want to
see is it even possible to beat these
warriors it doesn't seem possible what
are you thinking I don't think it is
possible for the current LeBron Lakers
roster to beat the Warriors and I'm keen
to see who has a roster right now to
beat the Warriors well in a seven-game
series just over to Houston
Carmelo's joining Houston yes and and
one would have to think one would think
again again he just he just had Paul
George and Russell Westbrook together
and it didn't work
see if Harden the defending MVP and
Chris Paul is a better yeah he did
really good I wonder if they're gonna
let Carmelo shoot a lot because harden
shoots a lot
that's a great question is out so how
how did he how do they split up the
basket because Carmelo loves to shoot so
I just was wondering um and they shipped
what's-his-name off to Canada what's his
name Hawaii and after they got Kawhi I
think I would have a different the
Lakers you're talking about
if data ended up with Kawhi be a
different comments well the issue
that Reverend is that that if Kauai was
able to be acquired by the Lakers who I
don't it might have been LeBron Kauai
Lanza ball and a bag of balls
essentially to roll out they would have
probably had to give him up way too much
to get Kawhi but maybe he'll come in
free agency how do you think LeBron in
this town knowing the town as well as
you you will will how do you think he
will grab this town I think he loves it
he's here to do business his kids go to
school he's here to do business
yes is a lasting way that you did I
agree he's here business he's here he's
ending in a place we eat he built his
nice new house is his children in here
he has his business partners here he's
doing a lot television stuff he's
speaking out he's building schools he's
a smart man he's very grounded and I
think you know he gave Cleveland with
the he gave me what they wanted right
gave him a championship game took him to
the championship a couple times um my
ego I might have stayed try to make
clean oh but he's pretty grounded and
smart lovable and giving and he's not
letting his ego getting away so I think
that he's doing the things to set up his
retirement
so when who's your your Nick of all time
who's your Walt Clyde Frazier you did an
hour Monroe
I'd have to split between those two and
I probably put them right together cuz I
can't diss either one but others but
them two together yes I've never seen
anything like it Clyde in the pearl clad
in pearl
I saw the Pearl the other day on the
train now I run in a lot of celebrities
you know this happens I'm like I was
scared to go say hi to him and then he
said to me and this would bloom I myself
hi mr. earlier pearl just shivering this
is like a couple like a couple of months
ago you think I knew that was you in the
adidas I was like I can't believe as a
kid I used to ride this Amtrak train
with my father to Baltimore so I guess
he was on his way in Washington he had
some business out there and my father
and I before he passed God rest his soul
would watch Earl the Pearl for him to be
mentioning my name being synonymous with
adidas blew my mind that he even knew
who I was it was just a mind-blowing
moment to be on the same Amtrak train
as Earl the Pearl they blew my mind and
when you were achieving your legendary
status at the very beginning of doing
that I'm just trying to think of where
the next war was at Bernard King the
Bernard King Iren extra I remember Hubie
Brown coaching the Knicks with Bernard
King out I don't remember I remember
that moment I think I was even before
that because Bernard King was after Earl
the Pearl yes there's a kid i was
looking at earlier pearl neil walk um
you know the the whole phil jackson did
me play for the next shirt to see how i
was a kid so yeah Phil Jackson ridl over
it had Reynolds yeah that's that's my
era of really watching it and fall
asleep on the couch my father Joey get
up joy get up going to bed you sleep
your dad I'm awake nice but I'm talking
professionally when you were starting
new ooo that's when I started when I
became run mm-hmm I guess it was Bernard
King I didn't know the clue up the
question was yeah I guess was Bernard
scoring what 40 some-odd point where he
we head back to well be a free world be
free free he was amazing he was amazing
he was a made you imagine if there were
three point shots four will be free it
was no three point shots then don't he
just shooting a man named only
counterfeit an art king was my god you
know I'm I'm 49 I'm from Staten Island
I'm 53 okay so we're not too far apart
but Bernard King was that uh that was my
fall in love with the next guy he had
back-to-back general voice Cheryl being
you know his brother was Dominique yeah
but people didn't give Gerald his prop
Gerald was bad on a Nick that's a bad
bad bad meaning good yes exactly
all right I want to take a 60-second
break come back talk a little bit more
sports and your ear with you if we can I
love it I'm not fantastic lie office you
got it thank you I will take that and
run with it thank you thank you Reverend
run is here Joseph Simmons all about the
Washington's check it out on Netflix
streaming on Friday we're back in 60
seconds
Rich Eisen show what was it like when
you were beginning your ascension of
your career with Run DMC what was that
like for you uh I was coming out of
being a 14 15 year old kid that worked
with an artist called Kurtis Blow hmm I
was the son of Kurtis Blow I wrapped
with him sometimes on the weekends and I
broke my arm and I used to DJ for him
and I kind of lost my job which was fine
cuz he was about to explode so he picked
up a guy that was older named Davey D so
as of my arm healed and it was too late
to get back with Kurtis and I did quite
a few shows with Kurtis Blow me and my
friend Darrell from Hollis Queens was
telling my brother and Kurtis we got
this other group that we put together so
putting together Run DMC was really it
was a big deal for me and Kurtis Blow at
that time was called the king of rap and
then it was only right that Run DMC me
being son of Kurtis Blow being the
Prince became king so why did you choose
your persona how did that come about um
well the whole Hollis Queens vibe was
swag you know you got the adidas you got
the Hat you got the way that the
truthfully here's a funny thing my way
of being run was I was dr. Joey dr. J I
had a six and a 32 and every time I
rhyme I actually thought I was playing
basketball
take a stand me everything in my mind
when I'm kicking my rhyme I'm a ball
player huh so that's basically it
everything comes from the suit and you
gotta think about it on the basketball
court there's a lot of crap talking yes
and it might be a rhyme or two went
around under my back up you can't catch
me it's like that you know something
like that so you kick a rhyme shoot it
in somebody's face talk some crap so
that's all basketball and rapper kind of
synonymous if you think about Allen
Iverson the swag that he had it wasn't
Allen was not only incredible in
basketball the way he dressed the way he
acted his attitude was very rap so it
kind of goes hand in hand yes and
sOccket ball and rap right and then
MTV comes along and they put us they put
Rock box what is the first um I wonder
the first maybe african-american groups
on MTV and it was a big deal but I
didn't know they came up to me I'm just
like young I'm probably 18 19 Oh your
your your videos on MTV and I'm like
what's MTV but I've never heard of it
MTV was brand new sure so it didn't they
were jumping up and down my management I
don't know what it was what was
yesterday's anniversary Chris yesterday
was the 30th anniversary of the premiere
of yo MTV raps
years later we were warned before yo MTV
raps but that wouldn't have been on the
air if you weren't on the air well yep
listen from your mouth to God's ears you
won't catch me braggin
I'm thankful I'll say it well thank you
you or make you welcome you're most
welcome it's it's fact thanks Ruth thank
you thanks truth and you know we're
talking today about one of the greatest
collaborations of all time and your
collaboration with Aerosmith is what is
wonderful isn't that correct it's
winning right now you have 40% how did
that come about um this is a good story
years and years ago before rap records
were made the DJ's job was to find
records that no one knew what it was and
you would scratch out the name so then
rival DJ's wouldn't know so we would rap
over this record in my mind called Toys
in the Attic I didn't know it was called
Walk This Way
so we were in there me and Darryl DMC
scratching up and making sure the vocals
don't play on a record called Toys in
the Attic Rick Rubin white dude walks in
and says oh you guys are playing Walk
This Way it's no we're not we're playing
toys an attic no this is Walk This Way
Joey and Darrell let's make it over like
make it over how we've never heard the
lyrics now we was scratching this record
up for years but a DJ would get in
trouble if the lyrics came in cuz you
can't rap over top of Steven Tyler
singing so the DJ's in trouble if the
lyrics and too much guitars show up so
the DJ job is back but pom-pom bat any
problem for you on that
your
bad DJ a terrible DJ if it goes past
perspective boom boom bad so Rick's no
no no go home and study the lyrics I'm
like how what is he saying
bag he'd love don't drive me become when
I talk to my daddy say you want me to
say these lines what does he backseat
love alone how to meet the couple when I
talk to my daddy
I ain't seen nothing to you down on a
muffin okay let's see how we gonna do
this dee please Rick we went home and it
probably was a 45 at that time so we had
to slow it down you have a 45 I've
walked this way now just take a 45 put
on 33 it gets worse but we come back we
do the best we can we like okay ready
darl
now Jam Master Jay God rest his soul is
there and we're like backseat look and
she's like do better than that you know
how to switch off switch off give it
your heart
so okay Dee Jay's gonna beat us up
backseat hard to come but you know we
were originally in the studio just
trying to rhyme our rhymes cause of that
beat right Rick Rubin changed that
course and made us do a remake of it
they called up Aerosmith Aerosmith
probably I think they were in rehab at
that time or something you know
something I don't know right and they
came to the studio cool as ever
nice guys Steve got on the mic Joe got
on the guitar collaboration gods
laughing I'm laughing with God number
one hit so they were brought in
essentially because to collaborate cuz
Rick Rubin said it would be a good idea
yeah to get them on it also but that's
the story boom I gave you a good long
story it's a great story
the whole 45:33 I gave it all to you
rich you've got it all I haven't told it
to many people that way you got how we
used to scratch the record got a lot of
stuff you probably did we helped
flattest places this is like royalty in
here got a good management team are
they're great here at 18 T so that's
amazing that's and that is the story of
walk this
perfectly told when was the last when
was the last time you we toured with
them for a while we toured with Daryl
Smith he killed it was us Kid Rock and
Aerosmith we opened with Kid Rock then
we do the middle no we'd open and then
we get on with Kid Rock and we get on
with arrows from sweet pose on three
parts of the show right and we would do
walk this way and end the whole show so
I opened and closed can't beat me but
you will open and you will go on with
Kid Rock and you close king run here on
the Rich Eisen show man this is great so
is there any concept maybe to do a movie
or the way that you start I hear about
it you know I don't talk about it much I
got I leave the business in Daryl's
hands he's very smart we have like the
number one logo in the world I'm sure
you see the Run DMC shirts everywhere of
course I leave straight out of Hollis
but I mean right boom it's no but I
don't know if they're gonna make a movie
out
I hear rumblings he into the left ear I
hear anything ready and I just want my
job at Netflix I'm gonna put out my TV
show me and my beautiful family all
about the Washington okay and if they
come along with a movie I'm like
scooby-doo ruh-roh who would you want
who would you want to play you
perhaps my son Jojo Oh diggie I don't
know
well maybe one of my kids they bit cool
cubed O'Shea play head Oh shake you did
he did he killed him he beat up that
office car going far at the bar was
soiid who so who will you tell this
story you told me back in the green room
who would be on the street in Hamas what
did you see growing up in Hollis you
told me Oh Steven Naismith is from
Hollis Queens two blocks from me I live
on 205 Street Stephen a Smith live on
two old third Street he walks down the
block would up Joey
you don't think nothing he's not
screaming he's not like one game one
game you mean to tell me there's not get
when one guy he's not that he's just
wound up Joey you see this tall guy
walking down the block I don't know he's
in the sports what up Steve a nun Joey
now
look on TV he's like screaming and and
no sports inside out
yeah also Kareem abdul-jabbar lived up
the block from me when he was going to
power high school onto 5th Street well
he was Lew Alcindor then Lew Alcindor
for sure yeah right on my corner nope so
you when you were walking down the
street in Hollis you didn't hear this
that was that was Stephen a-after
porzingis got drafted he did not say
that he never said that to me Joey
just a tall guy lanky walking like this
that's amazing
so maybe he can guest on all about the
Washington Sun definitely a chance on
Friday I think very fond of him he's
pretty fond of me we still cool a Harlem
noise yeah I bet so tell me about this
show it's how you came about what I'm
gonna try to short now how long I got on
it I was on LL Cool J's lip-sync battle
I went to do Christmas in Hollis there's
mine in my business and some guy comes
up with a pair of sneakers sign these
for me dude alright talk to my son Aidan
dude okay I'm sorry I'm ready to
Christmas in Hollis you by the way I'm
LL Cool J's agent I'm like cool man so
usually when somebody's a big run DMC
Finnair not thinking about runs how's my
TV show huh so my Brian is not thinking
he's about to pitch to me that I should
do a show like I'll ask NCIS over yes so
he's like what do you think is scripted
I don't like and I'm never caught off
guard I'm like this from Hollis I'm just
like jittery I know what's coming I
didn't not expect him to say that like
again usually a guy about his age grew
up on Run DMC Beastie Boys you just
happened to get you happy your sneakers
signed and be happy to be there but he's
he reached into a pocket I didn't expect
he's like what do you think of doing
scripted huh I like uh talked to my
manager Mike Lehman and next thing you
know he connects me to Amblin Steven
Spielberg's company ABC all these great
writers and all these people's name is
um Richard Weitz oh he's a top guy over
at WME I know him he pulled together a
team unstoppable
and next thing you know I got this big
showing on Netflix all because I'm going
to do Christmas and Alice at lip sync
battle and I guess you're an air own
show streaming on Netflix
BAM man that's the story I'm giving you
details you're getting like I'm getting
down to granular you're getting granular
yeah what's you understand by the way
that that would be the name of my my
hip-hop granny yeah I don't have it with
that similar granular getting granny
doesn't have a ring to it yeah I'm
trying to think of something that rhymes
with granular that that would be like
you just did not find a word that bad
can we just go an Isaac yes you can run
with them cuz I flies it I like it Joe
Biden oh this has just been all kinds of
fantastic thank you for coming on hey
man preach on a Sunday rap on a Monday
y'all do would run say to get better one
day just because Rev Run rocks a collar
don't mean I can't make a dollar you're
rich holla anytime
check out again all about the
Washington's on the Netflix streaming
that this Friday at Rev Run wisdom on
Twitter anytime anytime
deac e let's get Hollis and Staten
Island together anytime right around the
rich all it takes is a little fairy
right to the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience